o quadril bacia é composto de duas
partes principais que se encaixam como
uma articulação a cabeça do fêmur na
parte superior da perna e o acetábulo na
pélvis artroplastia total do quadril
bacia
geralmente é realizada quando a lesão
grave de artrite ou uma lesão dificulta
a realização das atividades diárias
durante o procedimento a cabeça femoral
e o acetábulo são substituídos por
componentes artificiais chamados de
próteses uma prótese de quadril
artificial consiste de um copo conhecido
como componente acetabular e uma haste
de metal chamada de componente femoral
antes de se submeter ao procedimento
serão administrados líquidos
intravenosos antibióticos e medicamentos
para ajudar a relaxar
um catéter será colocado na bexiga para
drenar a urina a maioria das
substituições de quadril é realizada com
anestesia geral caso em que um tubo de
respiração inserido na garganta para lhe
ajudar a respirar durante a operação
devido à perda de sangue líquidos que
pode ser significativa
o sangue coletado dos bancos de sangue
será preparado caso precise de uma
transfusão é possível coletar e
armazenar o próprio sangue na preparação
para a cirurgia
o cirurgião começará fazendo uma incisão
na articulação do quadril separando os
músculos e ligamentos para expor a
cápsula articular após incisão da
cápsula o cirurgião deslocará a cabeça
femoral do acetábulo será removido
qualquer osso ou cartilagem danificada
no acetábulo remodelando a cavidade
acetabular e fixando a prótese
acetabular no local usando cimento
especial ou parafusos voltando então ao
fêmur o cirurgião removerá a cabeça do
fêmur mudará o fêmur restante para se
ajustar à haste da prótese e fixará o
componente femoral com cimento ou outras
técnicas assim que ambos os componentes
estiverem bem encaixadas
o cirurgião deslizará a cabeça femoral
protética para o seu correspondente
acetabular testará o movimento da nova
articulação do quadril e verificará se
está corretamente posicionado através de
um raio x
em seguida
o cirurgião fechará a cápsula articular
e pará os músculos colocará um dreno no
quadril para retirar o excesso de
líquido e fechará a incisão com pontos
ou grampos
após a operação será colocado
temporariamente um dispositivo especial
para evitar deslocamento do quadril
você será transferido para a área de
recuperação pós cirúrgica até que esteja
estável e acordado da anestesia
se necessário é possível que receba uma
transfusão de sangue neste momento você
continuará com os líquidos intravenosos
e antibióticos por um curto período e
receber a medicação para a dor conforme
necessário é possível que o cateter seja
removido após alguns dias para evitar a
formação de coágulos na perna será
administrado anticoagulante deverá usar
meias de compressão pneumática e
recomendado começar a andar assim que
possível uma enfermeira ou
fisioterapeuta o ajudará a sair da cama
e usar seu novo quadril
a maioria dos pacientes recebe alta
hospitalar tão logo consiga andar um
auxílio de muletas ou andador